Something I've been thinking ton about is
kind of how we can embed our products into
agents. And when you think about what
the elements of a product are, you know,
you have docs. You kind of explain
what the product is, how to use it,
and the natural equivalent
of that is skills.
And then you have API calls, and you might
do those through tool calling, you know,
through an MCP or through a CLI.
But it's not really been a
great equivalent for UI yet.
You know, there's some
specifications around MCP apps.
There's some kind of MCP UI specs.
But I really wanted to take a look
at, like, specifications aside,
how can you start shipping
generative UI to your users today?
PostHog
And so, like, if I come over to
my editor, uh, to my coding agent,
PostHog and
it's gonna go ahead and run some queries
and find the answer to my question.
But, again, you don't get those, like,
visual elements to understand
basically what's happened.
And we put a lot of, like,
work as software engineers into being able
to effectively communicate through these
UI components what's
happening in the product.
So it's gone and found the results.
But what's cool here is I can actually
say, you know, let's see it as a chart.
PostHog and we'll dive into how that
works once it calls it.
But you can see it's figuring out
basically what the shape of the data is,
how to call it. It's figured that out.
Now it's calling the render UI
tool, and it's given me this link.
PostHog
And then I wanted to talk about,
like, basically, what's happened here,
and how how does this work.
And so we can actually see
what the agent wrote here.
So you can see that it calls render UI.
It calls code, runs this function,
and then returns this URL, basically.
And here's, like, a nicer version on
the side of, like, what that code is.
And you can see that it actually shipped
user query, and it has this query function.
For those of you that have ever
used something like tRPC or ORPC,
you'll recognize this as, a TypeScript
SDK that the agent can call.
And what's really cool here is you can
basically make a TypeScript SDK out of all of
your PostHog
I wanna, like,
peek behind the curtain and look at what
it looks like from the perspective of the
agent. So the agent gets four tools.
It has this execute tool, and
it has this render UI tool.
And then it also has a
tool for searching docs.
So just one by one, it's really
useful to ship a search docs tool.
Just, like, helps give the agent
information about how to use your product.
This execute tool is where
a lot of the magic happens.
So this is built on the executor SDK,
and I'll go over that in a second.
But it basically lets you take
any open API, GraphQL, MCP server,
and convert it to a TypeScript SDK.
And then the agent can
basically learn, hey.
You can have do this tool search.
You can describe it to
learn how to call it.
And then there's this render UI
function that when it calls it,
it gets basically some
information about, hey.
You write JSX.
TanStack Query And
so we can actually see it with
a much more complex dashboard.
And while that works, I'll go ahead and
actually talk about code mode for a second.
So this from Cloudflare's bot log.
They shipped this, and it's a really great
concept to go look into and understand.
Basically, you're able to ship your
entire a open API spec to agents,
convert it to a TypeScript SDK,
and then have them call it.
And I actually wanna dive into quickly
what that looks like from the perspective of
the agents. So, again, this
is, like, that execute tool,
and this is just a syntax highlighted
one, so it's a bit easier to understand.
And this is a really cool, like,
implementation of how you can let agents
write complex queries while still kind of
being in the constraints that CP has.
And so in this case,
there's this Google APIs function
that it calls to list my emails.
And in this case,
I'm trying to find response emails that
I've gotten from OpenAI or Anthropic,
and so it's filtering that down.
And, yes, look. It's all
built on these, like,
concepts that agents are
really good at writing code,
and you can basically give them
an environment to write that in.
And so coming back to the dashboard
that went handmade, so, again,
this is just a deep link into the product.
This could be into Postdoc.
This could be into WorkOS.
This could be whatever product you have.
You basically provide them a deep link,
and then you can run code in that deep link.
And so same thing here. It's running
this it's running all of these queries.
You can see on the side the code, and
we can take a quick look at the UI.
And then the last thing is this is
actually kind of officially supported by them,
SpeedySpec. So this is an
MCP app inside of Cloud Code.
And so when clients have
native support for MSP apps,
you can actually embed
it directly into clients.
But for any that don't,
you can just link out to the URL and start
to really ship great experiences to your
users. Thank you.